some radis 25 septembre c'est la journée
nationale d'hommage aux harkis ces
hommes engagés au service de la france
lors de la guerre d'algérie
commémoration ce matin à tours blois et
orléans comme vous le voyez sur ces
images au parc pasteur où une centaine
de personnes s'était réunie aux
invalides le chef de l'état a aussi
réaffirmé de nouvelles avancées en
matière de reconnaissance de réparation
et de solidarité envers elle les harkis
il y a cinq jours déjà emmanuel macron à
honorer une vingtaine d'anciens harkis
mais aussi des personnes impliquées dans
le milieu associatif
parmi eux tard à berkane un habitant
d'indre-et-loire promu chevalier de
l'ordre national du mérite
il s'occupe des droits des supplétifs
algériens engagés par la france et prône
l'échangé et le partage
intergénérationnel christelle chat
piotin et sa nasse nous ils ont
rencontré pour nous c'est un honneur
pour moi d'avoir cette distinction
néanmoins je pense que il aurait prévalu
dans un premier temps il reste peu de
personnes qui sont encore
vivante je dirais les plus jeunes entre
75 et 80 ans et qu'il aurait fallu un
moment donné plutôt privilégier cette
orientation vers les anciens tard à
berkane élevé au grade de chevalier de
l'ordre national du mérite
accepte la distinction au nom de
l'association de rapatrier qu'il a créé
il y a maintenant une douzaine d'années
l'idée c'est d'être toujours dansé dans
cette logique de mémoire et du souvenir
et de pouvoir honorer les morts
notamment les morts pour la france
on aurait le devoir de mémoire il le
fait régulièrement par le biais
d'interventions mémorial de l'aurès à
amboise
ce monument érigé en 1997 perpétue le
souvenir de tous les supplétifs morts
pour la france
de 1954 à 1962 tous ces glorieux
combattants n'ont pas eu la
reconnaissance et commentée de notre
pays ils ont eu le sentiment d'être
abandonnés par leur mère patrie
il faisait partie de tous ces régiments
de tirailleurs doivent spahis tabors et
de ses régiments qui ont fait la gloire
de la france
connaître et transmettre l'histoire
pourquoi pas en intervenant directement
auprès des jeunes et en participant à
l'écriture des manuels scolaires
moi je pense qu'il est important moi ou
d'autres représentants de l'association
parce qu'il faut il faut être dans le
dans le partage c'est qu'effectivement
soit des anciens ce qu'il ya quelques
anciens qui sont encore vivants qu'ils
sont capables de dire les choses soient
des représentants des associations
puissent intervenir y compris dans
l'écriture de ces manuels
parce que parfois il ya des choses qui
sont fausses
les autorités ne voient bien plus un
honneur et pour aller plus loin sur le
sujet l'invité du 19/20 ce soir et
saillies de bala président de
l'association des harkis du loiret
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer le
déblocage de 40 millions d'euros sur
quatre ans pour revaloriser les pensions
des harkis et venir en aide à leurs
enfants qui vivraient dans la précarité
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ces
mesures
40 milliards 40 pillon pardon c'est loin
du chiffre qui avait été annoncé au
départ par les associations qui étaient
finement de 40 milliards mais
c'est justin annonce là on nous dit pas
comment elle va être répartie donc il
nous dit que ça va venir
revaloriser les pensions et les
allocations servi aux veuves et aux
anciens harkis et en même temps aider
les enfants de harkis qui sont dans la
précarité
c'est une suite une aide sociale c'est
de la solidarité c'est parce que les
associations demandent des associations
demandent en fait que l'état reconnaisse
véritablement dans le cadre d'une loi
pas d'une résolution sa responsabilité
et de la répare alors que justement on
l'a entendue dans le reportage précédent
l'importance de ce devoir de mémoire le
gouvernement souhaite lancer des
initiatives mémorielle pour la
reconnaissance du sort des harkis qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
écoutez c'est ce qu'on sait c'est le
coup qu'on nous fait depuis des
décennies ont fait à chaque fois on
annonce ce genre de mesures au final il
n'y a pas grand chose monsieur aberkane
parler du mémorial d'amboise moi j'avais
participé à la maison place justement de
ceux de ce mémorial
ce qui veut dire que les associations
n'ont pas attendu l'état pour faire du
devoir de mémoire et rendre hommage à
laure à leurs parents alors combattants
ils ont en fait avec l'aide évidemment
de quelques élus et heureusement locaux
qui sont là fait déjà le nécessaire par
rapport à ça pour parler simplement de
l'association que je préside
on a on a bâti une stèle à ce mois en
hommage aux harkis et on a obtenu la
dénomination d'un square ingres et qui
va être inaugurée prochainement alors le
comité national de liaison des harkis
souhaite aller carrément devant la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
une véritable loi de reconnaissance vous
êtes sur cette même ligne
eh bien écoutez je pense que depuis le
temps qu'on attendait à mon avis
aujourd'hui la seule la seule voie qui
reste aux artistes c'est la voie
judiciaire et donc je pense que le
collectif a parfaitement raison
d'utiliser cette voie d'autant plus que
les juges ont reconnu dans deux fin dans
deux procédures précédentes la
responsabilité de l'état français de ce
qui est arrivé en algérie à propos des
harkis il a reconnu la responsabilité ce
qui est arrivé en france dans les camps
et cetera la décision est actuellement
devant le conseil d'état
il me semble il va ce sera donc une
décision à suivre merci beaucoup d'avoir
été l'invité du 19/20 ce soir merci à
vous